we've just doubled the size of our garden
and by the ‘we’ I mean
I gently bullied my husband into
building me two more planted boxes
but with the weather warming up and
the long weekend incoming
I did feel that intense of urgency
because if I don't get the plants on the ground like now
then we won't be enjoying their
beautiful produce all summer long
and a little birdie
told me that The Warehouse has an
incredible selection of garden supplies
including the healthiest little seedlings
at every day low priced
so today I went to investigate
and it turns out the bird actually did have the authority on the word
because I found some great bargains
including these ginormous tomato plants for only $10
which I've seen literally double the price elsewhere recently
I raced home and was so excited to get immediately stuck in
and I don't know what it is about the garden
but it's definitely one of my happy places
Mixed through some compost rush was
a steal at only $5.50 a bag
I planted a few varieties
of  peas before getting started on my strawberry patch
and I’m really looking forward to coming out here and picking strawberries
with the kids once they start ripening
I’m gonna train a couple of varieties
of courgettes up and over these trellises
I did half a dozen more peas before thinning my tomato plants
so they can focus more energy in on the fruit
then I planted a raspberry and a rhubarb
but I'm telling you I can just about
taste the Christmas crumble
I put in a dozen lettuces from two variety packs
so they’re all  different types which is perfect
cos we’re definitely big salad people
and I finished up by planting my agria seed potatoes
Which in about 90 days should be ready to harvest
Now is definitely the time to be planting your summer garden
and The Warehouse has a great range
if you’re on the hunt